and i'm going to read this
you're going to listen to it
whether you like it or not
this is from the daily wire it says
according to the national aeronautics
and space administration
something weird is going on in the
universe
you're just going to sit and listen to
this
nasa made the determination by examining
evidence gleaned from the hubble space
telescope deep in space which has
measured the speed at which the universe
is currently expanding which is much
faster than the speed of the expansion
of the big bang
nasa writes the cause of this
discrepancy remains a mystery
but hubble data encompassing a variety
of cosmic objects that serve as distance
markers support the idea that something
weird is going on possibly involving
brand new physics
this is actual this is the scientific
language from nasa something weird's
going something weird is going on here
that's scientific length but it is it's
interesting and that's why i'm going to
continue reading it
scientists had assumed that gravity
would slow down the universe's expansion
over time dr kathy romer of the dark
energy survey told the daily mail the
universe is not only expanding but it's
expanding faster and faster as time goes
by what we expect is that the expansion
will get slower and slower as time goes
by because it has been nearly 14 billion
years since the big bang
14 billion years okay it's a long time
that's an interesting length of time i
would even say
nasa explains when nasa conceived of a
large telescope in the 1970s one of the
primary justifications for the expense
an extraordinary technical effort was to
be able to resolve
um cepheids stars that brighten and dim
periodically seen inside our milky way
and external galaxies
using these stars discovered by
astronomer henrietta swan levitt in 1912
scientists measured distances in the
universe they then used exploding stars
called
type la supernovae to measure greater
distances using both approaches
scientists could estimate the hubble
constant named after scientist edwin
hubble a value that can estimate the age
of the universe by measuring the
expansion rate but some of these
calculations are breaking down to the
point and so they're just confused by it
right
this interesting fact about space that
i'm telling you you go tell your friends
about it
all right
we got through it together
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content